I can't get over the fact that I'm
paying the price for some dark politics
between Iran in the UK in 2016 nazan
Enzo Garry Radcliffe took her infant
daughter on holiday to visit family in
Iran she's been a prisoner since accused
of spying her husband Richard on his
fourth visit to the UN General Assembly
in New York calls her a hostage held he
says for political leverage you're right
Nazarene was convicted of a crime all
the hostages to the held have been put
through some sort of legal process it's
a placebo process so she wasn't allowed
to speak her trial her charges were
never made public even to her every
Gibbons the prison and she was convicted
having been told that listen if the
British government makes the agreement
we won't charge you at sentencing
Nazanin is not alone Iran is currently
thought to hold up to 30 dual nationals
whose families insist they did nothing
wrong
this year we launched a family's
alliance with the number of families to
say listen the world needs to do more to
protect me from state hostage drinking
now Iran is particular conspicuous and
doing it it's not the only country that
does it and there is a way in which
actually the world needs to worry if
this can happen more and more
none of us is safe with tensions in the
Gulf spiraling an international effort
is underway to broker new talks with
Iran presumably for you negotiations are
a good outcome at this point conflict
would not be without doubt as the
tradition of war is not good for my
family one of the things I've seen this
week is there's been an increasing
pressure on Iran to say it's
unacceptable this cannot be allowed to
continue my job to the British
government say listen I think the most
important thing is to put ordinary
people first to have ordinary citizens
at the absolute center of any
negotiations in a recent phone call
Nazanin said I truly hope this will be
the last time that you go to New York
for the UN I hope that this time it pays
off in very blunt terms and we're not
talking about releasing somebody we're
talking about some point saving
somebody's life
the attritional quality of being held in
the sort of arbitrary brutal way it has
a decimating impact
nazaneen-e a Gary Radcliffe has
previously been on hunger strike and
there are deep concerns for her mental
health as events evolve on the
international stage over which the
family has no control there are only the
faintest hopes of an imminent release
Jonah hull al-jazeera
at the United Nations in New York